we got a certified chad looking dude in
the house so what's happening with you
man
howdy how's your day going it's going
good
yeah
so
i'm going to give you the longtime
listener first time caller read your
book blah blah
so to dovetail off what the last guy was
saying uh so the us army not saying who
my current employer may or may not be
but uh the u.s army has banned soldiers
from utilizing tick tock because it's
run by the chinese communist party so
now they're here there
but if i say um you know
your red flag chapter gets talked about
a lot and rightfully so
um a while back you did a video about
your green flags
which i think would make a great
addition to the book um because i think
that's at least is equally useful what i
would tell people is you know i would
try to always learn something from
everybody i meet sometimes you learn how
not to be what to look not for what
sometimes you learn how to be what to
look for
i think your green flags video was super
useful
um
and so you know i presently am seeing an
entrepreneur she doesn't see herself as
such but
she doesn't like me to
advertise
her net worth but it's
it's a significant number and uh she's
my job title right now on the civilian
side because i may or may not be an army
reservist and i may or may not
work in the army one week in a month uh
but on the civilian side uh if i were in
the army uh my job title would be
business intelligence architect and so
i'm north of 200k and she
makes several times what i make and
she's asked me the question recently why
don't why don't you start your own
business and i'm like that's a great
it's a great point because she's made
the point
you know the industry why are you making
money for someone else when you're
making money for yourself and um so why
do i mention this um
you've talked about um you know in some
of your red flags i think you've
mentioned uh dating older women so i'm
36 years old uh i have two young
children from prior marriage she's older
than me she's a few years older than me
and so what's that how old is she she's
46.
that's not a few years older that's a
decade older
uh you know when i was 25 i would have
probably said the same um but uh you
know i'm not the young spry chicken i
used to be uh but i can certainly say
after a hike in uh the mountains of
north carolina when she kicked my ass
and left me in the dust that she's in
better shape than i am i'm stronger than
sh
she's a 46 year old um entrepreneur
she's divorced or
yes same yep we both have been carried
with two kids you said uh she does not
uh i have two kids i have two young kids
from prior marriage okay so she doesn't
have any kids she does not um
so you know i i've often wondered having
and i wondered this frequently while
reading your book i wondered what would
rich think of this particular female and
at this point as i said first stroll
don't need anyone else's uh opinion but
i always value outside
objective viewpoints so based on the
snippet i've said i'd love to hear your
thoughts i suspect i already know what
your thoughts are but i'm not in the
habit of assuming so i just as soon ask
you the question and hear what your
thoughts are on the matter
as i have some now
um what are my thoughts is i wouldn't do
it
okay
but that's me i mean look i know that
there's some attractive looking
mid-40s women out there
but they can't hold a candle to a woman
that's younger to
younger to them if they're also
attractive and fit and also a mid-40s
woman is closer to menopause than a
25 or a 35 year old woman
right so she might look good
right now
oh fair point
that uh you know that time in a woman's
life comes hard and fast and it takes
absolutely no prisoners whatsoever i
mean at 36 i mean you could be dating
women in their 20s right so oh my
question i have for you is what's so
special about a woman that's a decade
older that runs a business
multiple businesses in this particular
case and i've uh been with women half
her age in the last year and uh
i gotta say uh
i uh
i appreciate someone who takes care of
themselves i appreciate someone who has
ambition
uh and you know obviously i never
introduced my kids to someone unless
i've been seeing them for at least six
months
and she's about your kids she has yeah
uh
great uh they love her and she loves
them
uh and right now
fair
fair i don't think that's likely to
change um are you sure about that no of
course not absolutely not i i worked in
intel when i was in afghanistan my job
was to make predictive forecasts about
when the taliban was coming before they
show up
and we got pretty good at because we
you know quantified and brought
objective data sets to make those
predictive forecasts good and you know
so you can never fully predict what
someone's going to be like in the future
but the best predictor of future
behavior is past behavior right and so
uh
i can say that uh uh
unabashedly that
uh i'm not concerned about her liking or
loving my kids because she spent enough
time around them
and um
but
you know
we talked about the red go ahead let me
just hover on that kid thing for a
minute all right like like kids are kids
are always cute like there's always cute
moments you get an ice cream in their
hand you take them somewhere that they
like they're excited they have cute
moments right but then there's the
moments where they don't get their way
and they throw a temper tantrum or she's
been there for that or that you got to
travel somewhere and there's chaos and
stress that's you know that gets added
to the equation and then you know she
starts to look at them like well those
aren't my kids
not my monkeys not my circus right um
men are very willing to accommodate the
offspring of another man but i found
women hard-pressed over a long-term
basis
to be
enthusiastic about raising the offspring
of another woman
so that's a great point and i you know i
don't want to over delve into into your
personal business your personal affairs
i've watched a good number of your your
past um podcasts i haven't watched all
of them but i know you've talked about
how you have a daughter from prior
marriage and at least at one point i
think while you were writing your book
you had been seeing a female who i think
at the time you had said had a had a
good at least rapport with your daughter
yeah and you know
i would love to hear from an
entrepreneur someone who has started
business
don't expect a woman to ever play the
role of mother to children that aren't
theirs
certainly not and i think the reverse is
also true don't expect a man who is not
the biological father of the children to
ever play father to but they are
expected men men are expected to step up
and you know be the be the father that
stepped up not be the step dad you know
is the uh meme trope that you hear a lot
right
and and it is and there is absolutely
double standard in our society um
so you know
what what i see so i have a son and i
have a daughter and uh you know i've
been taking both my kids to the home gym
ever since they were each a month old
you know i remember when they were each
a month old i'd have them down there
uh my daughter is four and my son is two
oh they're still small dude they're
always cute at that age right wait they
wait till they are eight nine ten years
old and they start to have opinions and
then you know 10 11 12 and they start to
have very differing opinions
so to that point and i'm glad you bring
that up opinions uh in children are not
what we should base our how we act on
but it's not something to preclude
either and i'll say this
um
i don't want to disparage their mother
um
i was with you i was right i was with
her for for a variety of reasons i'm sad
that things didn't work out um i tried
to save the relationship and she wasn't
interested but neither here nor there i
will say this um when i look at the
woman i've seen i've been seeing now for
the better part of the last year um
she's a physically fit strong
you know she's the type of female that
you know when i was in my 20s and did
not have a high opinion of myself and
did not have a high net worth
um
that i didn't i thought a female like
her was beyond me for lack of a better
term and you know you talk about younger
females having been with younger females
in the last
year plus i can certainly say that this
particular individual i know menopause
in that comment is a fair is a fair uh
criticism for like better term it's a
fact biology yeah it at 100
and let's be real about about biology
let's be real about science and about
about what's what's coming of course the
same is true
to a lesser degree for males but
obviously your points do not um
falter on the point of the female i'll
say this she's more attractive than
females i've been with who are half her
age um and in terms of the
she's not the first female i've
introduced to my children
but she's the first female who stuck
around because my kids are the ultimate
litmus test
and when my kids didn't like a past
female she got kicked to the curb my
kids love her she seems to love her uh
or she seems to love the kids
you know
you know what your your kids are at the
age where they would really appreciate
disneyland or like universal studios
so what i want you to do is i want you
to ask your girlfriend say hey babe i
got a great idea let's take the kids to
disneyland
well we've been actually talking about
doing that funny you should mention that
um do it
come back and
report to me how that went uh you know
what i uh suspect that that may likely
happen i'll say this i know your time is
valuable so i do want to be respectful
of your time um
i look at her and i'm not so concerned
about my son
i figure you know you know your kids are
clearly very important and and it's a
big factor of why you're dealing with
this chick instead of a 26 year old i
get it
i absolutely get it
so i'll say this and and then and then
i'll i'll drop off here because again i
do want to be respectful of your time um
you know i would love to know about more
about you and and what you're
basically like better from how your
relationship is with your daughter and
how things have turned up not in any
sense of of judging in the sense of
learning from someone who's been there
done that
but i will say this
i look at my girlfriend now and i look
at i look at my daughter and i think
this is the female i would love for you
to mirror
maybe not exactly i don't want you to go
down the exact path that she has gone
down but this is a strong successful
female
who
i think can model what a confident
female can be like
and
that is a a model
that and it is a double standard i don't
worry about my son because i i feel like
it's my job to raise my son to be a man
but i also want to
be i want to present a positive role
model for my daughter so she knows what
to look for in a male but i also want to
have positive female role models in her
life and i look at my girlfriend now and
i see that so you know
i've been thinking about calling into
your channel for the past year since i
read your book and this first time i've
done so um
and i i suspected you would have
hesitations we'll call it uh and and
this has been exactly as i more or less
exactly as expected um
you know
but i would
you know i would love to in the future
perhaps a year down the line you know do
a follow-on call with you and you know
how things turned out um i'd love to
hear that update because everybody
watching right now is going to look
forward to hearing how it's all
unfolding and i don't wish like [ __ ] on
anybody like i hope it really works out
for you that you get exactly what it is
that you want out of it
um but it's a moving target and there's
no unicorns and time and sunlight you
know will
reveal what somebody's all about
absolutely you know throw some chaos and
some stress into there and you know see
how things unfold but
right now you're doing the classic
complicate life justify why i like her
she's pretty she still looks hotter than
me she can hike better than i can a real
question somebody put in the comments is
how is she more fit than you are if
she's 10 years older and you're a man
oh she's got way better cardiovascular
endurance than i do hands down she she
was a triathlon
athlete she did iron man's back in the
day
uh you know i'm way way physically
stronger than her if when we go to the
gym together i i can lift multiples of
what she can but her ability to outlast
me is okay yeah
i mean like you're basically looking for
permission to like you know take this
further and it's like you don't need
anybody's permission no like if i don't
working out for you then continue doing
it but proceed forward with you know
like be observant
of what's going on you know see how
things unfold with the kids because one
of the biggest reasons i hear you
selecting this chick as a girlfriend as
a partner a mate whatever it is you want
to call her is because she's good with
your kids is because she's successful is
because you don't need to support her is
because she encourages you to be better
sort of thing that's a big part right
there right but there's a reason for
that right she's she's 46 and she would
normally be dating guys her age or
probably older
some of them might have some performance
issues in a bedroom by this time if they
don't know how to take care of their
[ __ ]
right but she's got money she doesn't
need money she needs you know she needs
somebody to entertain her she's got
youth and looks in you you're a
big successful military guy right she's
saying start your own business why
line somebody else's pocket with gold
when you can build something for
yourself it's a very good point why
wouldn't you want to hear that
conversation she's saying be better hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you